hey you guys flickers of fear time now
you guys
if you've been watching my show for any
length of time you'll know what a
massive fan of david lynch i am
and actually we haven't uh tom's not a
huge fan so we don't do a lot of david
lynch on the show i actually did do a
review of mulholland drive which is
probably one of my favorite movies of
all time not even probably easily one of
my favorite movies of all time and i did
that by myself like a few years ago and
went on and on for almost an hour about
it which is something that happens when
i start talking about david lynch movies
particularly mulholland drive because i
think it's just honestly it's my
favorite movie of his and it's kind of a
masterpiece
so i had been wanting to do some more
david lynch and so i ordered a couple
that i didn't have and uh this is one of
the ones that i ordered this is lost
highway now i had actually seen this
probably i don't remember if i saw it in
the theater i very well might have uh it
got kind of a very limited release so
maybe i didn't but i'm pretty sure that
i saw it like not too long after it came
out back in 1997
and i remember really liking it then but
it didn't stick with me the same way
that mulholland drive did and in some
ways i feel like lost highway is almost
like
i want to say it's like a practice run
for male 1 drive
but
thematically uh visually it's very
similar like it explores a lot of the
same themes um there's a lot of the same
symbolism there's a lot of the same um
you know kind of plot tropes of you know
identity switching and uh you know kind
of dream narrative i guess uh and in a
way i kind of feel like lost highway
mulholland drive and the movie that came
after it which is inland empire which
i'm going to get to eventually because i
bought that one as well are almost kind
of like a weird like loose trilogy
because not only are they all concerned
with
reality versus
subjective interpretation sort of themes
but they also like i said have the same
symbol symbolism in a lot of senses and
they also all kind of explore um
hollywood in a broader sense like
and they're all kind of like meta
commentaries on film and film making in
general so in that sense i kind of feel
like lost highway was the first one of
that and even though i love lost highway
i feel like those it didn't really come
to fruition until mulholland drive which
like i said i think was his
i think that was like such a
distillation of all of david lynch's you
know thematic things that he likes to go
into and i just think that was perfectly
distilled in a way that
uh was still accessible to
audiences but still retained that
mystery that puzzle box thing that he
had going on whereas i feel like when
lost highway first came out you know as
with a lot of david lynch movies i feel
like when it first came out in 1997
critics were kind of like real mixed on
it like some of them recognized that it
was a great movie but then some of them
were kind of like you know siskel and
ebert most famously they were like you
know it doesn't make any sense it's like
you know not a straight ahead narrative
and stuff which like i said that's kind
of been thrown at david lynch a lot but
rewatching it again because like i said
i kind of feel like i maybe haven't seen
lost highway for at least 10 years maybe
longer
watching it again especially after
especially in light of
re-watching mulholland drive several
times like in the last few years
and so watching lost highway again
through that lens to me it almost seemed
not straightforward but it seems a lot
more coherent than maybe it was given
credit for at the time and maybe that's
easy for me to say now because i'm going
back you know in hindsight it's easy to
say because after mulholland drive came
out and
that one like i said it's not
straightforward but if you watch it
enough times um the structure of it
becomes a lot more apparent and i'm not
saying that there's one
easy way to solve it um you know there
are multiple interpretations but i think
you know the the main overarching uh you
know
narrative of it is kind of like pretty
straightforward and i think lost highway
is kind of the same so
it's interesting so now i'm going to
have to like watch inland empire and see
if i can because i've only seen that one
a couple of times and that one has like
i said also a similar thematic thrust of
you know narrative identity and
you're
almost like the way reality sees you and
the way that you see yourself like maybe
your subjective interpretation of
yourself your subjective interpretation
of events um that seems like a big theme
in all three of these movies so yeah so
i think what ended up happening with
this one so
the movie that he'd made before lost
highway was twin peaks firewalk with me
which is another one that i own and i
will eventually get around to i want to
do like a whole twin peaks
thing like with the movie and because i
have all three seasons on blu-ray as
well uh and i kind of want to do like a
big mega episode at some point
i don't know what i'm gonna get around
to that but uh you know watching all the
episodes and watching the movie as well
but you know up until then i wanted to
do some more like little bite-sized
lunch so uh so yeah so he had done
firewalk with me and even though twin
peaks the tv series was very successful
um he made the movie as sort of like a
prequel
and it didn't uh really do all that well
which i don't really get because i think
it's a really awesome movie but you know
that's how [ __ ] goes so then lost
highway came out and as i said it seemed
like
i don't know it seemed like some critics
kind of recognized
uh you know how good it was from the
beginning but a lot of them didn't a lot
of them just didn't like uh that it
didn't seem like a straight ahead
narrative and they just thought that it
was incoherent which like i said i would
argue with that it's really not but uh
you know in the subsequent years i feel
like it's really picked up
a lot of occult following and people
have actually kind of like figured out
like i said it's not to me it doesn't
seem like that hard of a movie to figure
out uh especially in light of mulholland
drive which came later on and you know
like i said if you would if you kind of
like put the same interpretation of
mulholland driving this one like with a
few little tweaks it's sort of you're
sort of like seeing the same thing so
what happens in lost highway uh bill
pullman plays a guy named fred
and he is a saxophonist like a jazz
musician he lives in la with his wife
renee who's played by patricia arquette
now at the very beginning of the movie
you kind of see a few things about these
two the main thing being that they seem
like they're in sort of a loveless
marriage i guess they're a little bit
distant a little bit cold there's kind
of like um there's a kind of
uncomfortable sex scene like early on
where
he's kind of into it and you can tell
she's not really into it and you know
he's be she's being like kind of
condescending like it's okay you know
what i mean and he's you can see he's
kind of seething about it now into this
uh he also kind of seems to suspect that
renee is probably cheating on him
because he's going to play at this club
like he does i presume most nights of
the week and she tells him you know oh
i'm not going tonight i'm just going to
stay home and read but then when he
calls the apartment like later on no one
answers the phone
although when he gets home she's there
but he's still like suspecting and then
he remembers back that when he was at
the club he actually thought that he saw
her like leaving the club with this
other dude that she knows so there's
that whole thing going on so he's kind
of operating under the assumption that
she that he can't uh satisfy her and
that he and that she is uh cheating on
him although he doesn't have any proof
of that now into this situation they
start to receive a series of very
strange unmarked vhs tapes which kind of
turn up in these plain manila envelopes
and they turn up like on the front steps
of their house
now the first of these just seems to be
someone with a video camera like filming
the front of their house which is creepy
but you know they're just kind of like
okay uh whatever
but then they start getting more of them
and it starts getting a little more
sinister because then not only do the
videotapes show just the outside of
their house but also shoes the inside of
their house too and it looks like
someone is walking through their house
and essentially videotaping them while
they're sleeping and that weirds them
out and so they call the police now the
police uh they come there and they kind
of
you know they they kind of take it
seriously but they're just kind of like
well you know uh we can't find any
break-in we can't you know you maybe you
should just get an alarm system and
they're like well we have one we just
haven't been using it because it kept
going off so they're like well maybe you
should just start using it because you
know nothing bad has happened but you
know this is like not that good so just
keep everything like locked down tight
now during this sequence when the police
are there
uh there's a very interesting line that
fred played by bill pullman says that i
think is sort of like the key
to i don't know if i want to say the key
to unlocking the whole narrative but he
does say something very interesting the
cops actually ask him if he has a video
camera
and his wife renee says no uh fred
doesn't like them because and then fred
says you know that cops are like well
yeah why is that and uh fred says oh
well i like to remember things my own
way not necessarily the way that they
happened so
again we're going into a very david
lynchian particularly during this
during this span of films this trilogy
of films
where
what you're seeing on the screen isn't
necessarily what really happened it was
someone's subjective interpretation of
it whether it was a dream about it or
whether it was like the way that they
were recasting it to make themselves not
the villain or something like that which
i think is the case here so after this
point it gets to a it gets to a thing
because i this is where i think a lot of
people like got confused about the movie
because it's not kind of like mulholland
drive i kind of feel like has a similar
structure although mulholland drive you
kind of felt like it was this straight
ahead narrative for like half or three
quarters of the movie and then all of a
sudden the blue box opens and everything
just everything's different like
everybody's different this one is almost
kind of like the flip side of that
because there's like a little bit at the
beginning with uh with fred and renee
and you kind of know what's going on
with them and the videotapes and
everything
and then
pretty early on in the film there's kind
of like a reversal and then suddenly
you're following some other guy
now one thing i will note in the first
part of the film which is concerned with
fred's character
is that him and renee go to this party
and while they're at this party uh
fred's suspicions about renee cheating
on him with this dude named andy uh kind
of get a lot more pronounced because he
sees them interacting with one another
and they seem kind of like flirty and
touching like hey let's not you know so
he's kind of like okay and then you know
basically renee's like hey why don't you
go get me a drink and i'm just going to
be over here with andy kind of thing and
he's just like okay i see how this is
going now while he's going to get the
drinks there's a very famous scene
when he goes to get the drink and he
runs into this very very creepy dude
played by robert blake
uh whose character is just credited as
the mystery man and the mystery man
basically says to him we've met before
haven't we uh to which fred is just kind
of like no i don't remember that now uh
you i will note that that prior to this
fred had a nightmare he tells renee
about it and basically says i was
walking down the hall and i see i saw
you in bed it looked like you but it
wasn't you and then he sees her wake up
and basically she has the mystery man's
face for a second and then like he wakes
up and sees her as she normally is so as
a matter of fact he has seen the mystery
band before but
it was ostensibly in a dream so the
mystery man says to him
you know we've met before and he's like
yeah i don't remember that as where do
you think we've met before and then the
mystery man says at your house don't you
remember and he's like yeah no i don't
remember that and then
one of the creepiest lines in the film
and i've said before david lynch can
creep me out like nobody can creep me
out it's like every time even watching
this again even knowing that scene is
coming it doesn't creep me out as much
as the winky's diner thing from uh from
mulholland drive does but still every
time he talks to that mystery man and
the mystery man says we met at your
house don't you remember he said matter
of fact i'm there right now
and he makes that crit that creepy
creepy face and so he could basically
like fred calls his own house and the
mystery man answers even though he's
standing right there you know he's like
how did you get in my house and he's
like you invited me in uh i'm not in the
he says something like i'm not in the
custom of going places where i'm not
wanted so there's this whole kind of
like situation you're just like what the
[ __ ] is that all about he gets creeped
out as [ __ ] as you would and he's kind
of asking andy
the guy he suspects his wife is sleeping
with um you know who is that guy and
she's like oh i don't know his name he's
just he's a friend of dick laurent now
dick laurent is a character that will
come up a little bit uh later and one
honestly i think it might be the very
very first scene of the film like after
the credits that fred is in his
apartment and somebody comes over his
intercom and says declarant is dead and
he doesn't know who that is and he
doesn't know whose voice it is and he
goes out there and there's nobody there
so
he says to andy he's like well isn't
isn't he dead and the guy's like well i
don't know um you know i i don't know
it's
is he dead i didn't know that and he's
like oh well i don't know either i don't
know the guy so like i said it seems
random but this makes sense like later
on so basically what happens after that
is there's uh there's a scene where
he goes into the house uh you know he
sees renee in bed she kind of seems
alarmed to see him and then it kind of
like cuts to black and then there's like
some flashing lights and stuff which
in a david lynch movie um
and even in in mulholland drive
specifically he always uses like this
kind of like color symbolism um blue
essentially in like flashing lights like
blue flashing lights anything like that
blue usually
symbolizes it's either kind of like
crossing a veil between two kind of
things or
uh the presence of evil that's another
thing um or revelation of truth i've
seen that you know he's but he always
uses that blue light like meaning
something like that so
at this point in the movie uh he kind of
like there's a scene like that and then
the next morning you see him come out
and renee isn't there and he has another
videotape and he watches it by himself
prior to this him and renee had been
watching them together and being like
creeped out like why is somebody filming
us while we're sleeping but now he
watches it by himself on this particular
videotape it shows that fred has
actually killed renee and chopped her in
half much like the black dahlia i don't
think that i've seen any other
there must be some other reviewer that
brought that up but it's like i didn't
even notice it like the first time i
watched but her body is bisected like
she's cut in half so it's like really
really gruesome and they only show it
for like a second or two but i'm pretty
sure that he was um that david lynch
because he's very into like old
hollywood lore and so he's always like
making references like that you know
like i said the mulholland drive had
like a lot of um references to like
sunset boulevard and stuff like that
um so i definitely think that that was
something to do with like the black
dahlia murder so he has cut his wife in
half like it's on the videotape now at
this point uh fred gets arrested for the
murder of his wife and he's put on death
row
now while he's on death row uh one of
his guards is henry rollins by the way
which i did i totally forgot that he was
in this movie he's only in it for like a
minute or two but yeah so while he's on
death row he starts complaining about
headaches and all this other kind of
stuff and then there comes a point and i
think this is kind of where everybody
was like okay now i don't have any idea
what's going on because prior to this
like the story was pretty
straightforward um it was just kind of
like this couple that were having
problems and somebody was watching their
house and then it looked like he killed
his wife um so he's put on death row but
then uh you get the blue flashing lights
again and then suddenly uh fred is not
in the cell anymore now it's a guy named
a younger guy named pete
who's played by balthazar getty now the
cops are just kind of like mystified as
to how this could have happened he's
like hey what happened to fred the guy
that was supposed to be in here this is
like some other dude named pete so
obviously they have to let this guy go
and uh pete does not seem to remember
how he got there or what happened or
anything like that so from this point of
the movie we're following pete's
narrative now pete is a younger guy and
he works at a garage
and he's uh pretty pretty uh popular
with the ladies he's got a girlfriend
named sheila and then there's some other
stuff that happens later on
but so he's working at this garage and
uh this gangster mr eddie who we learned
from the bunch of cops because there's a
couple of cops that are tailing pete
because they're like well we need to
find fred the guy that was supposed to
be in the cell and so maybe if we tr if
we uh tail pete we'll figure out like
what happened to fred so they're
following pete around uh you know kind
of on the down low
so uh so they say you know this this guy
this gangster named mr eddie who's
played by robert loja he comes to the um
to the garage this is apparently his
favorite garage and he really really
likes pete to work on his cars because
he's like the best mechanic in the area
so he comes there and the cops at this
point say you know oh mr eddie that
gangster his real name is dick laurent
so now we're this is like the where the
uh two narratives become tied together
right because dick laurent is apparently
a character in both of them now at this
point so pete fixes his car there's a
kind of like a very funny sequence which
reminds me of the sequence in mulholland
drive where they go to get that black
book and like they go in that office and
like end up shooting all this like the
the guys end up shooting all these
people randomly so it's like it you know
accidentally so there's a funny sequence
where the gangster mr eddie is in the
car with like two of his thugs or
whatever and then uh you know uh pete is
in there too and there's a guy
tailgating and apparently
apparently mr eddie really really
doesn't like that so he um
he uh
basically runs the tailgate or like he
lets him go around and then he runs him
off the road and like threatens him and
beats the [ __ ] out of him and stuff
because he's just like really really not
having the tailgating so it's like it's
this funny sequence but it's also
supposed to show it's also supposed to
show that mr eddie is not only like a
violent you know dude but also someone
who's very very willing to
essentially kill somebody for for
you know transgressing like pretty minor
rules so there's that whole thing too
now it so happens that when mr eddie
brings back one of his other cars to get
worked on at the garage he has with him
his latest
girlfriend conquest whoever this
beautiful platinum blonde named alice
now alice is also played by patricia
arquette
so obviously her and renee the woman
from the first part of the narrative
like with fred are either they're
supposed to be like doppelgangers but
honestly i think they're the same person
and i'll get into that in a little bit
now almost immediately pete is drawn to
alice and alice seems just as like you
know drawn to him eventually she comes
back to like pick up the car and or she
basically comes there in a cab like
later on that night and is like hey
let's go to dinner so she's you know
just trying to go after this kid and
he's just at first he's kind of like
yeah i don't think that's a good idea
because you know you're the girlfriend
of a very dangerous gangster but uh he
can't really resist her so they start
unwisely having an affair now as it goes
on mr eddie seems to find out about this
affair and uh [ __ ] starts going bad so
basically what alice tries to persuade
uh pete to do
is hey um i really need to get away from
mr eddie because there's kind of she
goes into this thing where uh basically
her friend andy who was also in the
first uh in the first narrative with
fred you know the guy that fred
suspected that she was sleeping with he
had like gotten her a job and the job
ended up being essentially in porn but
she doesn't like say that outright but
it does like come to light later on at
which point pete gets kind of jealous
and annoyed and [ __ ] like that about her
being in porn and everything and she's
saying she wants to run away she can't
get away from mr eddie he's like too
powerful so she says what we're gonna do
is we're gonna go to andy's house
um you know and i'm gonna like you i'm
gonna [ __ ] him or whatever and then
you're gonna be there and sneak in the
house and you're gonna knock him out or
we're gonna rob his [ __ ] and then we're
gonna like take off and we'll you know
we'll all go off and be together
now
at this point so alice is essentially
like your traditional film noir like
femme fatale type of character and again
this is kind of like
she's a different side of renee like i
said these two women are the same woman
you know what i mean but yeah i'll get
into that a little bit in the same way
that mulholland drive you know what i
mean you have uh you know the main
character who who's betty and who's you
know diane
it's the same person so this is kind of
like the thing that's going on here so
they go to andy's house uh the plan
seems to be going okay although i don't
know necessarily um andy ends up getting
killed pretty much uh in a pretty
gruesome fashion alice doesn't seem all
that upset about it and she's just kind
of like okay well let's get the [ __ ] and
we'll get out of here i know a guy who's
offense we'll go there we'll get the
money and then we'll get the [ __ ] out of
here
so they go out to the desert
and it turns out that the guy who's the
fence or the guy the place where they go
is this cabin out in the desert and in
the cabin is the mystery man
now the mystery man has also turned up
in pete's narrative
uh he is a friend of dick laurence just
like in the original part of the fred
narrative that you know he was told at
the party
and he is also i don't know like what
role he plays necessarily like i said it
doesn't matter because i don't think the
mystery man is a real person either but
he essentially says almost the same
thing over the phone to pete that he
said at the party to fred earlier he
basically says you know we've met before
haven't we and he's like very menacing
and essentially mr eddie is saying
something like he sort of obliquely
warns him that he knows about the affair
with him and alice and that he's uh
gonna kill him at some point but he's
not gonna tell him when because it's
gonna be like a big surprise so it's
kind of like this oblique uh sort of
threat that he's giving him what ends up
happening after that is that when they
get to the desert they go in the cabin
nobody's there but then um so pete and
alice like have sex in front of the car
like in the headlights like in the
desert or whatever at night and then
after that like pete keeps saying how
much he wants her and uh then she kind
of like just cuts him off with you'll
never have me and then walks back into
the cabin and then she disappears at
which point pete turns back into fred
now
after that they kind of go back to this
is it's kind of like a time loop sort of
thing so
you can kind of extrapolate like what
quote-unquote really happened and what
is just like a subjective interpretation
of it but the timeline of it isn't
entirely clear because there's one point
where the mystery man comes back to the
cabin once uh pete has turned back into
fred and then the mystery man tells fred
something like you know her name's not
alice like her name's renee if she told
you her name was alice she was lying and
then he says what's your name what's
your [ __ ] name so again fred and pete
same person uh just different just
subjective interpretations and like i
said this is why the line that fred says
at the near the beginning of the film
about he doesn't like videotapes because
he doesn't like to remember things the
way they actually happened he likes to
remember things the way he wants to
remember them and that's essentially
what's going on here so after that like
the mystery man uh you know mr eddie
shows up because it turns out that renee
his wife from the first that he killed
she was the one that was in porn she was
the one that got that was in with mr
eddie that was sleeping with mr eddie
that was working with alice it was
making porn films she was doing all that
it wasn't alice like i said that was the
same person
and so what essentially ended up
happening was that fred had gone and to
this motel called the lost highway it's
actually lost highway hotel and he found
renee and mr eddie or dick laurent
together and um after suspecting that he
had gotten her into porn she was in porn
he thought she was a [ __ ] so he ends up
killing dick laurent
or mr eddie and later on killing renee
so fred actually did do all this he was
actually married to a woman named renee
uh he did find out that she was having
an affair with mr eddie and possibly
also with andy he also found out that
she was making porn films also there was
kind of like some snuff film action
going on there as well he found out
about all that and ended up killing mr
uh like dick laurent
and ended up killing his wife and so and
he did get arrested in reality and he
did get put on death row however once he
was put on death row he began to
dissociate and see himself as pete in
the same way that uh that diane in
mulholland drive is recasting herself as
betty this sort of innocent wide-eyed
you know person who never did anything
wrong and just got suckered into bad
things by other people like she's kind
of you know absolving herself of
responsibility that's the same thing
that fred's character is doing he can't
deal with the fact that he killed his
wife that he's that person so he had to
dissociate from himself and play and
essentially recast himself as this
younger guy who
turned up in the death row cell but he
didn't do anything um he got roped into
doing things by alice this femme fatale
who was like the the bad parts of renee
um you know so that was like that was
her that side of her the one that
essentially so what fred is essentially
trying to do is he's trying to blame his
wife
for the things that he did because she
was a bad person she was a [ __ ] she was
cheating on him uh therefore she
deserved it and he just kind of got
roped into all this and it wasn't really
any fault of his own so that's kind of
like what
so again this is why this is very
similar to mulholland drive because
that's a very similar narrative too it's
basically somebody that can't deal with
like the horrible reality of what they
did of their own life um you know much
like in mulholland drive where she paid
to have a hit out on her girlfriend uh
and then couldn't deal with it so she
had to like recast her entire life as
this other you know is this other thing
where she couldn't possibly do anything
wrong everything was outside of herself
like she wasn't responsible for anything
anymore and that's kind of the same
thing that happens here he did all these
things but he wanted to blame her she
was a bad person she had it coming um
you know i'm just this
young guy this innocent guy that got
they got roped into all this by this
terrible woman um you know and i didn't
expect it to end up like this it's also
kind of um telling that when he recasts
himself as pete he recasts himself as a
much younger guy
and a guy who doesn't have any problems
getting women i mean even the cops that
are tailing him like make a make a
statement he gets more [ __ ] than a
toilet seat like they say at some point
so that's like significant because if
you'll remember like near the beginning
of the movie that like that awkward sex
scene between fred and renee where it's
clear that fred is not really like doing
it for her anymore and she's just kind
of laying there going that's all right
honey you know it's that kind of thing
so it's just like this very awkward
distance between the two of them but
when he recasts himself he recasts
himself as this dude he's got a
girlfriend like sheila who's kind of
like on the side and then when he starts
seeing alice like she's like insatiable
she can't get enough of him and it's
like she's calling him all the time and
they're having like super hot sex all
the time so it's funny that he's sort of
like recasting himself in that light
because he was like an inadequate lover
i guess in real life so he was kind of
like trying to try to make it like he
was this big stud and then he just got
[ __ ] over by this woman and yeah i
killed her but you know what are you
gonna do she was a [ __ ] she was a
terrible person she talked me into doing
all these things and i didn't really
want to do them so that's essentially
what the movie is about he's just kind
of trying to absolve himself of the
responsibility of what he did now
like i said there's multiple
interpretations i watched a couple
different um interpretations of this and
i think one of the interpretations i
watched he said that
one he thought that the mystery man was
a representation of evil
i think well that's kind of true as far
as it goes honestly i think the mystery
man who does not exist by the way i
think the mystery man is
he could either be the same as like the
bum behind winky's diner in mulholland
drive as in
i don't think it's necessarily the evil
it's kind of like the evil that fred
does but it's also like the realization
of reality because i kind of feel like
the bum behind winkie's diner had the
same kind of symbolism where
this is not only like the ugly side like
all the shitty things that you did that
you don't want to face up to but it's
also a symbol of your realization of
finally coming to you know coming to
terms with the fact that this is what
you did that this is the evil that's
within you so i guess it's sort of like
evil in that sense but like i said he's
also it's significant that the mystery
man is seen as the one with the
videotape all the time and the in the
sequences that are on videotape uh you
presume is the reality of what happened
because of the line that fred gives in
the beginning that it's like he doesn't
want to know what really happened he
wants to remember things that he wants
to remember them so so i feel like not
only is the mystery man yes he
represents
all of the evil inside of fred because
significantly it's the mystery man that
gives fred
the knife and the gun that he uses to
kill mr eddie like near the end but he's
also
trying to show him
what he really did you know i mean
because he's trying to like get away
from it he's trying to know i'm pete i'm
i got suckered into all this uh but the
mystery man is trying to like show him
these videotapes no this is the reality
and he's just not wanting to see it
until the end also i'm kind of torn as
to whether pete
is a person in reality or or if the
whole part like of the whole pete
sequence is just
fred but recast as a different so i
don't know if pete exists outside of
fred's subjective reality if that makes
any sense because i did see another
interpretation where they said they
thought pete was a real person and that
maybe
he was someone that fred had seen at
some point or you know
related to for whatever reason and then
decided to recast himself as that person
even though he didn't know anything
about that person which has ha that
happened in mulholland drive too um you
know where people that diane saw in her
real life uh she recast in other parts
like in her dream narrative so that
might be the case here like maybe pete
is a real person but nothing that you
see pete do
uh you know in the movie i don't think i
think that's all fred i think fred did
all that [ __ ] i'm i'm not real clear on
killing andy though so i don't know
i kind of feel like maybe fred killed
andy as well because this other
interpretation i saw they said no well
probably pete actually did kill andy but
i don't think that makes any sense
because i think pete and fred are the
same person so
i think it would stand to reason that
fred actually killed not only his wife
and mr eddie but i think he also killed
andy as well you know because it makes
sense because they go to the house and
it's like he doesn't
initially mean to kill andy he just
means to like knock him out so they can
take his [ __ ] but then andy kind of like
gets up and like runs at him and then he
kind of like throws him and he crashes
his head into a coffee table so he
almost kills him quote unquote
accidentally so again i think that's and
you know trying to absolve himself for
responsibility so i definitely think
that fred probably killed andy as well
because everything you see pete do even
if pete is a real person outside like
but i don't think he has anything to do
with the narrative you know what i mean
i think he's just he's just a cipher
he's just a symbol of
fred's
trying to make himself seem innocent or
trying to like get himself out of like
all of the bad [ __ ] that he did because
he can't deal with it so you know that's
what i'm saying but yeah i know this has
been kind of like rambly as all my david
lit [ __ ] is it's like maybe it's more
coherent than it's sounding like to me
that sometimes happens but whenever i
talk about david lynch movies i just get
really excited and i'm always just kind
of like remembering all of the stuff
that happened in it and then like after
i record i'm just kind of like oh [ __ ] i
forgot to bring up this that and the
other thing but i think i kind of
covered most of the bases as i said uh
my favorite is always going to be
mulholland drive i think that's his
masterpiece but i think it's really
interesting that
this movie
seems like i said almost like a dry run
from all hallow drive it's not
the same but it's very very thematically
similar um you know there's the whole
thing about voyeurism the whole thing
about there's like a meta commentary on
filmmaking and it's like you know is
what we see on the film like real or is
like you know it's and it's almost kind
of like we're making a film of
quote-unquote reality but it's not
really reality because it's a film and
so he's kind of like making that as well
i think everything was a little bit more
coherent like i said in mulholland drive
but
if you've seen that one and if you kind
of have been following david lynch's
stuff and his um you know a lot of the
themes and symbols that he keeps coming
back to honestly i think lost highway is
pretty straightforward in that regard uh
i didn't find it particularly confusing
i didn't really find it all that
confusing the first time either but
watching it the second time i think this
is only the second or third time that
i've seen it it was actually very very
clear to me like what was going on i
don't know and maybe people just weren't
ready for it in 1997 i don't really know
it it would probably play a lot better
nowadays because i feel like you know
his people are a lot more maybe
sophisticated about that or have seen
that before so it's kind of like you you
know
how to um you know interpret things
symbolically things don't have to be a
straight ahead narrative you know which
this is not some of it is
you know some of it's reality all the
stuff with fred and renee at the
beginning and you know the stuff near
the end that's reality like something
really did happen but you're just seeing
intertwined with that you're just seeing
someone's subjective interpretation of
what happened the way they wanted it to
happen but not the way it actually did
happen so that's all you're seeing but
yeah so visually this is really cool i
want to point out too how awesome the uh
soundtrack and the soundscape for this
is uh just a [ __ ] great i mean he
uses like a lot of stuff that
i feel like normally he uses kind of a
lot of you know bluesy jazzy kind of
stuff but there's a little bit of that
in here but in this he used like a lot
of he used like uh you know trent reznor
did a lot of music for this like there's
marilyn manson romstein um he did uh
that's there's this mortal coil uh that
song uh song to the siren which is in
here like three times which is a
beautiful song and i love that yeah
david bowie they used like deranged at
the beginning and the end which i
thought was uh fantastic so it's just
the soundscape of it everything about
this is just like a visual treat and an
auditory treat as many of his movies are
but yeah great film uh i feel like it's
appreciated now more than it was back in
the day and i'm glad to see that uh so
if you haven't seen it if you only see
mulholland drive maybe check this one
out and uh you know tell me what you
thought about it and that will do it for
this flickers of fear and i will see you
guys on the next one
bye